[D. Evans] There are lots of different ways you could have solved this.
You need to use the print command to print out the result,
and then we want an expression that calculates the number of minutes in 7 weeks.
There's 7 weeks. Each week has 7 days.
So you can have 7 * 7 for the number of days.
Then to get the number of minutes we need to multiply that by 24
to get the number of hours, and then multiply again by 60.
That should give us the number of minutes.
Let's see that in the Python interpreter.
Now we hit Run, and we see that we have 70,560 minutes.
It seems like a lot of time. It's going to go pretty quick.
We hope by the end of the 7 weeks all of you will be accomplished Python programmers.